hey way to get some big belly burger you
decide to play nice might give you the
fries
[Music]
got my hood
hey everybody Roy is back are you
wearing my hood it actually looks pretty
good on you I think it's funny that he
doesn't know that Thea's been wearing
his costume ever since he left the TV
show but there was that big rant that
she went on everything had just gone to
crap since Roy left so we got really
meta this week especially that
conversation that Oliver had at the end
where he's like yeah you should you
should just take off with him which I
feel like is setting the stage for Willa
Holland the actress to leave the TV show
if you're finding me for the first time
be sure to subscribe to get all the DC
videos there's a flash ring giveaway
that's going on in all these too so
obviously careful for spoilers from the
episode if you haven't seen it yet
pretty much they're big Roy is back art
he's back in next week's episode too but
that's mostly a Thea driven storyline
because of what's going on with Nyssa al
Ghul so I'll explain that at the end of
the video but if you are a big Green
Arrow comic book fan you probably
spotted the broken comic book arc that
they sort of weaved into this episode
we're basically Diggle gets trapped
imagine all the stuff that happened to
Roy happened to Diggle in the comic book
richard dragon was the villain of that
storyline his team was called the
longbow hunters the people that were on
his team were a little bit different
like on the show they have Anatoli they
have black siren but in the comic book
it was count vertigo brick red dart and
Killer Moth so the TV shows kind of
doing their version of that but the way
they explained boys backstory is that
he's been in st. Roch this whole time
hiding out that's actually where the
Hawks are from if you don't remember
that they mentioned it on the show hey
every once in a while you have to
imagine that the Hawks are out there
somewhere they still have their powers
so maybe they're traveling around the
country who knows what they're doing but
as far as we can tell he hasn't really
been doing any vigilante work on his own
like he's just been Roy Harper trying to
hide out lay low so that people don't
find him because if you don't remember
he outed himself is the green arrow to
get all of her off so he's still a
person of interest even though they're
now on Oliver Queen being the green
arrow because of the FBI case but
obviously Ricardo Diaz tracked him down
because he wants to use him as a
leverage against Oliver Queen and he's
just trying to beat a confession out of
him I think they did a good job of
framing Roy's character like when they
find out at the begin
the episode that he's the surprise star
witness that's going to be testifying
against him
they don't believe for a second that
he's turned on the team they immediately
just go to oh he's being forced to do
this we need to rescue him he's probably
being held against his will so this is
them wanting to let you know that
they're not gonna demonize Roy like Roy
is very clearly being forced into this
situation otherwise he would do
everything he could to help out team
arrow but when Kate Spencer came back at
the beginning of the episode and she's
like yeah this FBI case this is gonna go
away I was like wait a minute
what's been the whole point of this
storyline the whole time other than to
drive team arrow apart like I feel like
that's the only reason they're doing the
Oliver Queen might be out at his Green
Arrow so that they can force Rene into
that situation drive the team apart and
do this new team arrow versus old team
arrow obviously the team is gonna come
back together by the end of the season I
don't think we're gonna go into season
seven with two completely different
teams but this episode sort of seals the
deal because now they have Roy
so Ricardo Diaz doesn't have any of that
leverage so that whole arc that that FBI
lady got this season is basically just
collapsed and thrown into the garbage
but the four dimensional chest the Diaz
is playing because even though he
doesn't have the entire City Council on
his payroll he says that pretty much
everybody on the council wants the
vigilante bill to pass they wouldn't be
able to operate at all plus you have the
fact that Ricardo Diaz has all that 70
million dollars now that he's using to
fund his drug company out of corto
Maltese the drugs that Diggle was taking
that he was making a ton of money off so
he's basically like this giant drug
kingpin in Star City now but the police
captain also wants to sell off all those
seized assets and make another 30
million on top of that that they'll
either turn around and stick in their
pockets or funnel back into the drug
empire so they're really just putting
more and more money into Diaz's pockets
the whole point in getting rid of the
green arrow and team arrow is that it
just makes it easier for him to sell his
drugs there's nobody to stop him from
doing it then there's the whole black
siren arc which I think it's pretty
clear that she's trying to play both
sides like she's sort of her own faction
by herself
amidst all these villains and heroes
like she's just looking out for black
siren she's just gonna flip-flop
whenever it suits her I don't think
she's ever gonna commit to one side of
the other but I do think it's really
gonna come to a
when Quentin's life hangs in the balance
like she'll save Quentin but she's not
gonna be a good character and she's not
gonna keep pretending to be earth one
Laurel so straight observations I know
you have a lot of questions about this
League of Assassins person that's
sitting outside Roy and Thea's window
watching them get it on at the end of
the episode she's part of that Thanatos
guild storyline that they've been
teasing for the past couple of months
Nyssa al Ghul is coming back for an
episode and it sounds like based on her
conversation that she has with whoever
she's talking to that they're trying to
reform the League of Assassins
using the air of racial Ghul so the big
question is is why do they think that
Thea is the last heir of Rachael Ghul
maybe it has something to do with how
she was resurrected in the Lazarus Pit
who knows but I feel like they're just
trying to give Thea like a really big
story to go out on this season if Willa
Holland does leave the TV show like I
said all of us conversation when we find
Roy not if but when we find Roy I think
maybe you should go with him
we're wherever he's going I mean I'm D
I'd miss you like my crazy but you said
that you haven't been the same without
him so maybe you shouldn't be without it
you should go with them wherever he goes
we don't want to see you leave but it's
probably the best thing for you so
that's like probably one of the most
meta conversations that they have during
the episode the actress Willa Holland
made no secret about the fact that she
wanted to reduce her episode count the
last couple of seasons like give me less
episodes so I have more free time to do
other things so now I think it just got
to the point where she's like how about
you just make me a guest star that comes
back for one or two episodes next season
the other thing I liked about the
episode was the way they referenced
berry like the nurse is talking about
how it's ridiculous that earth one
laurel has come back after she
pronounced her dead like oh I ran the
autopsy she was definitely dead but if
there's a man out there that can run
faster than light then we have to
believe in the impossible so believing
in the impossible is actually the speech
that Barry had in that opening narration
of the very first episode of the flash
to understand what I'm about to tell you
you need to do something first you need
to believe in the impossible can you do
that that's me
not to so let me know in the comments
what was your favorite part of the
episode what do you think about Roy
coming back and for those of you asking
about Roy Harper on Titan's there have
been a lot of rumors in the past year
about him being a character on that TV
show but most people that are talking
about the show as if they have some sort
of insider information are saying that
it's actually going to be a younger
version of the character and it will be
recast so that means that it would not
be Colton Haynes but because they still
have a long ways to go filming that
season and we still don't have
confirmation on Donna Troy or some of
the other big Titans characters I think
it's gonna be a while before we get any
confirmation on that like yeah we're
gonna do Roy Harper and yeah it's gonna
be a different version of the character
but no worries as we get new Titans
information I'll do new Titans videos
they still have a lot of episodes left
to film so there's a lot of information
that we'll be learning in the next
couple of months but what will happen is
is there'll be more Marvel videos
posting really soon there was just like
this Avengers motherlode that just
dropped so I'm still working through
some of that they just confirmed that
Black Panther 2 is going to be happening
and what'll happen is I'll just name the
giveaway winner when I post new DC this
weekend so click here for my new
infinity war preview video and click
here for my flash video from this week
thank you so much for watching I'm good
to stay awesome see you guys tonight